they'll make us thought the fans would
never notice but they were wrong these
are the sequels that ignored major
Cliffhangers the most significant
cultural impact at the very long Friday
the 13th film series is that it made
homicidal maniac Jason Voorhees an
iconic character he's certainly
intriguing and mysterious and he kills a
total further concealing his identity
behind a creepy hockey mask Jason Loom
so lives that is easy to forget that
he's not the chief villain of every
Friday the 13th movie for example his
mother Avengers his death in 1980s
Friday the 13th and he doesn't begin his
Killing Spree until 1981's Friday the
13th part two with this leading title
and twist ending 1985's Friday the 13th
a new beginning and sets up its own
franchise for a soft reboot in this the
fifth Friday the 13th movie Jason's
original killer Tommy Jarvis remains
haunted by the murder but would adjacent
imposter hunts Tommy to avenge the death
of his son Tommy defeats the Killer and
takes on the identity and mask of Jason
Voorhees this means in the next movie
Friday the 13th part 6 Jason lives Tommy
as Jason is a central villain right nope
the 1986 sequel begins with Tommy who's
played by a different actor digging up
Jason's corpse to burn it unfortunately
he accidentally resurrects the Killer
and with that Jason loves to strike
again
slasher movies thrive on jump scares and
sudden twists and since I Know What You
Did Last Summer was something of a Next
Generation no master slasher Flix and
the 1997 horror film made good on the
promise of shocking and unexpected
deaths one of them comes at the tail end
of the movie when a character played by
the most famous person at the time
seemingly dies in a grisly fashion
[Music]
the entire movie is about four teenagers
who spend a year attempting to evade
death by Revenge from a raincoat wearing
stranger they unintentionally killed in
a traffic accident as I Know What You
Did Last Summer reaches its conclusion
it seems like Julie James played by
Jennifer Love Hewitt isn't the clear
she's left home and is attending college
in Boston but when she heads into the
shower one day she sees I still know
written in the Steam on the shower door
her an Avenged victim slash killer shows
up Suddenly Judy screams and the movie
ends at that point the viewers can
assume the raincoat man kills Julie
quickly and efficiently but the 1998
sequel I Still Know What You Did Last
Summer begs to differ Julie is the main
character in the movie she apparently
didn't die or even fight off her
attacker because the film makes no
mention of the final horrifying moments
of the first film while 2015 xansman is
more comedic and absurd than a typical
Marvel Cinematic Universe entry the film
Stakes remain very high Dr Hank pin
played by Michael Douglas develops a
suit that can shrink a human after he's
kicked out of his company by his
one-time Protege he recruits Scott Lang
played by Paul Rudd to stop that villain
from figuring out the same Tech and
using it to carry out unfathomable acts
of evil the whole point of Ant-Man then
is to stop the all-important attack from
getting into the wrong hands but it does
a Hydra agent named Mitchell Carson
flees pimp Technologies with some
yellowjacket particles and runs after
Parts Unknown where does he go and how
does he use yellowjacket particles to
advance his own agenda audiences never
find out because neither of the sequels
Ant-Man and the WASP nor Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania follow up on Carson
when confronted with this lack of plot
development and man director Peyton Reed
explain the unresolved Cliffhanger he
told Cinema Blend but there was a
sequence where Ant-Man has an encounter
with them but then for a couple reasons
I felt like maybe we should leave those
particles out there
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a
perpetually complicated and intricate
network of films but each entry directly
connecting to so many others that's how
Marvel Studios keeps audiences coming
back for more we have to know what
happens next but certainly after the
post-credit sequences after the credits
and big credit scenes rolled in the 2016
MCU movie Doctor Strange viewers who
stayed in their seats caught one more
sequence It Centers on mordo a
supporting character who trains Dr
Steven strange in the use and History of
Magic the after credits scene really
seems to set up mordo who's portrayed by
Academy award-nominated actor she would
sell ejo4 for a solo movie Disney plus
series or significant plot Arc in a
future film in the sequence mordo
discusses the overabundance of sorceress
on the planet with fellow magical one
Jonathan Pangborn as such mordo
presumably heads out to knock off some
Wicked wizards but viewers never see
that happen not even as a Multiverse
possibility in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness in fact he's
barely in that movie in 1999 Sony bought
the rights to make movies based on
characters in the Spider-Man universe
and later produce a Spider-Man trilogy
after its Rivals at Marvel Studios
started up the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Sony ramped up to stay competitive
rebooting the franchise with the Amazing
Spider-Man in 2012 and The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 in 2014. Sony has since
released a couple of Venom films three
more Spider-Man movies and more BS but
the company never made a project
featuring The Sinister Six a team up of
the biggest baddest and most famous
villains from the decade's old property
among the antagonists Dr Octopus Electro
Mysterio Sandman vulture and Craven the
hunter but it looked like Sony had a
Sinister Six movie in the works around
2014 which had later confirmed according
to deadline a sequence in The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 offers a quick glimpse of
costume and prop elements of sinister
six members such as vultures wings and
dog to octopus's tentacles and the Green
Goblins glider among other teasers while
some of those villains turn up in later
Spider-Man movies starting with the MCU
base Spider-Man homecoming The Sinister
Six movie that was so blatantly promised
never came to fruition
in parts of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides rakish and roguish pirate Captain
Jack Sparrow finally seems to have met
both his romantic and adversarial match
in Angelica played by Penelope Cruz
she's a pirate as crafty and daring as
Captain Jack and she claims to be the
daughter of the legendary Blackbeard
Oscar winner Cruz came on board the
Pirates of the Caribbean franchise
nearly a decade in and injected new
energy into it both on Stranger Tides
would Mark her and Angelica's one and
only appearance in the series growing
weary of Angelica's machinations and
unwilling to trust her Jack abandons her
on a tiny Island before returning to his
life of independent piracy and heading
off to find his lost ship that's how the
movie ends but a post-credit scene shows
audiences what happened next a voodoo
doll that looks like Captain Jack washes
up on Angelica's Island and it's evident
she plans to use the Darkly magical
object to exact revenge on him Jack
Sparrow dealing with a voodoo curse
should have been a big part of the plus
of 2017's parts of the Caribbean Dead
Men tell no Tales but it isn't Angelica
doesn't even show up on sequel
Prometheus a prequel to The Alien series
is slow cerebral and requires intense
concentration from audiences Ridley
Scott who directed the initial alien in
1979 Helms a 2012 movie which purported
to set up the events that led to those
other Blockbusters in the film two
scientists lead a deep space expedition
to explore Humanity's possible
extraterrestrial Origins and just like
in the other Alien movies there's a lot
of foreboding death and destruction
Prometheus winds up with optimistic
spiritual scientist Elizabeth Shaw as
the only human Survivor on a ship along
with an Android named David at the end
of the film Sean David seek out the home
planet of the menacing Engineers to
discover what they wanted to exterminate
All Humans a sequel to Prometheus alien
Covenant hit theaters in 2017. sure only
briefly appears as a corpse experimented
on by David who also destroyed the evil
alien threat from the first movie sure
and David's interactions with the
engineers are not discussed and so their
motivations remain a mystery the 2000s
action movie franchise triple X
positioned itself as an edgier James
Bond series for a new generation Vin
Diesel Stars Asanda XXX cage an extreme
sports athlete who cheats death as a
matter of course and is recruited by the
NSA to be a top spy unlike the ongoing
Bond franchise which is primarily a
string of self-contained movies the
three XXX films will follow a sequence
of events that makes a filmmaker's
decision to ignore some Cliffhangers
very confusing to viewers at the end of
2002's XXX Xander cage completes his
mission and is enjoying some well-earned
rest and relaxation and handlers
approach him with his next big spy
assignment as the film ends it's unclear
if he's going to accept the job and
nobody ever finds out because diesel
didn't want to return for 2005's xXx
State of the Union The Story Goes that
Xander cage died off screen while ice
cube plays a new agent named Darius
Stone but then diesel returned in 2017
for the third film triple X return of
Xander cage meaning the character never
really died after all
since launching in 1996 the mission
impossible franchise has become one of
the most successful action series of the
past 30 years 2011 for the fourth entry
of the franchise arrive in theaters
titled Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol
introduced a new team of IMF agents who
are working with Ethan Hunt to try to
clear their names after they are accused
of planting a bomb in the Kremlin these
fresh additions for the series included
Jeremy renner's intelligence analyst
William Brandt Simon pegg's field agent
Benji Dunn and Paula Patton's agent Jane
Carter after they are successful in
their mission hunt gathers everyone
together again at the end of the film
and hands them another one implying that
this group will continue to work
together as a new terrorist organization
emerges unfortunately fans never got to
see any more of Carter despite the fact
that other characters from the film
reappeared in subsequent releases with
little mention of her it is unclear
where she is or what might have happened
Carter was seemingly set to return to
the franchise but rumors suggesting that
she would have appeared in Rogue Nation
but scheduling conflicts meant her
character was Kurt from the film before
the Marvel Cinematic Universe became the
juggernauts it is Marvel Comics fans had
the X-Men series to keep them occupied
beginning with the first movie in 2000
the franchise balloons of more than a
dozen films 2006 saw the release of the
third movie in the series X-Men the Last
Stand it follows Magneto and his
Brotherhood of mutants as they attempt
to prevent a cure for the mutant Gene
from being forcefully imposed on mutant
kind it also features Jean Gray
unleashing the Phoenix Force ultimately
killing professor Charles Xavier and
allying with Magneto the movie ends with
a post-credits scene where a coma
patient and a hospital wakes up and
talks with the voice of Charles Xavier
this suggests that Professor X has
somehow survived by placing his mind
into the body of another person but
Charles Xavier played by Patrick Stewart
returns in three sequel films he first
makes a cameo in a 2013 film The
Wolverine before becoming part of the
main cast again in the 2014 release
X-Men Days of Future Past and 2017's
Logan it unclear how Professor Rex was
able to return to his normal body as it
had apparently been disintegrated by
Jean Gray no explanation is given either
he simply tells Wolverine that he too
has gifts but he doesn't reveal what
happened between the films
as I told you a long time ago
you're not the only one with gifts one
of the defining aspects of the James
Bond movies is that different actors
have played 007 over the years of course
this tradition only arose because
original actor Sean Connery left the
franchise when he departed following the
release of you only lived twice in 1967
George Lazenby took on the role of the
fictional spy in 1969's on Her Majesty's
Secret Service the latter film follows
Bond as he tries to stop blofeld from
destroying the world's food supply by
the end of the movie bond has fallen in
love with Contessa Teresa Tracy D
vicenzo portrayed by Deanna Rigg the two
eventually marry though the relationship
is cut short when they're involved in a
drive-by shooting at the hands of
blofeld and his henchwoman Tracy is
killed and bond is left devastated by
the events producers were able to
convince Connery to return for diamonds
are forever and the opening scene shows
Bond tracking down and killing who he
believes to be the real blowfower yet no
explanation has given as to why he is so
determined to despise the villain and
Tracy isn't mentioned at any point in
the film in fact there are some
suggestions and the opening moments that
bond is actually pursuing blofeld
directly after the events of You Only
Live Twice
[Music]